Stephen Miller points that he says you
know Jake you keep getting things wrong
here in your keep you keep trying to
push a narrative and it's a little weird
buddy and all of a sudden Jake Tapper
cuts him off that's the thing you get
out of this interviews Jake Tapper
doesn't want his answers he doesn't want
to hear anything from him he wants to
cut him off and push a narrative Stephen
Miller points this out and this I think
is the central takeaway from the
interview all these so-called political
geniuses in Washington whether it be at
the big you´d lobbying firms or in the
last week is the president but you guys
happens to be a true statement okay it's
self-made billionaire who revolutionize
reality TV and Hoosiers the Cory's Brock
is happy that you said that buddy
no no you might be condescending and
it's ending he's been in you can be
conscious and that was a snide remark
you're sure he's watching he's happy let
me tell you something why is Network you
can look you can be as condescending as
you want it's part of your mo but listen
the you can have 24/7 I have no idea why
you're attacking me man it's stupid I'm
not being condescending I'm not being
passive-aggressive how many how many
times has anyone ever said I'm not being
passive-aggressive when they when they
weren't being very very
passive-aggressive this is this is what
is really sad about Jake Tapper he used
to especially during the Obama years he
was a pretty tough journalist played it
straight when a lot of the media were
fawning over Barack Obama he didn't do
that he just played it as a kind of
straight faced guy going for the facts
and now he's this whiny shallow petulant
little schoolgirl who says well I'm sure
your boss saw it and he just saw what
you said man oh he'll be so happy about
that but anyway moving on like are you
kidding me buddy that you're supposed to
be the last newsman in America why are
you getting these snide little barbs in
this smug smarm you don't need to do
that and by the way Stephen Miller is is
a robot you can get very unemotional
answers out of him but Jake Tapper
himself can't refrain from being
emotional in this interview that's why
Miller says stop being hysterical why
are you trying to make this all personal
why are you trying to get little barbs
and insults and I'm giving you an answer
Jake Tapper revisits this later in the
interview there's one view
that you care about right now and you're
being obsequious now being a phantom in
order to please him wasted enough my
view was like you know as Republicans to
resign two aspects of this one he has to
cut him off because Stephen Miller isn't
saying what he wants him to say so he
isn't going along with the the pre
scripted interview that Jake Tapper
clearly had outlined in his head so he
has to just cut him off very rudely it
was really awful even from the beginning
to bring up those personal insults and
Barb's is so rude so unbecoming of a
serious newsman but Jake Tapper hasn't
been a serious newsman for a very long
time but to get that same exact Barban
again it was pathetic I mean it was the
sort of insult that you would hear in
middle school you would hear somebody
say well I know that really secretly you
only care about this it's not even
psychobabble psychobabble is much more
elevated than what Jake Tapper is doing
here to Stephen Miller and the and
that's where it really takes a turn
because Jake Tapper having once been a
journalist he is now fully at CNM he's
doing the CNN thing God knows why his
bosses may have told him that he had to
turn up the smarm and the smug he's
basically auditioning to be Jon Stewart
outside of this interview here are some
other examples apparently does not like
any questions about any of this not a
ban okay but I could have sworn I heard
somebody in the Trump administration
using the term ban before was it
possibly president Trump okay but to be
fair that was Sean Spicer on Sunday
surely he has not used the term ban
since then such as I don't know last
night when he spoke at George Washington
University it's all sarcasm it's a
dripping and sarcasm and he's he's so
regularly missing his role if he the
world that he once served as being a
journalist of a straight journalist
everything now is so elitist and so
condescending as Stephen Miller
I wonder if he had that even loaded up
and ready to go to accuse him of being
condescending the Trump administration
is very good at branding people finding
an essential flaw in their character and
pulling it to the forefront and showing
that to people that is Jake Tapper's
Donald Trump I think has made the guy go
completely mad and he can't help he
wears his hatred and fury and madness at
Donald Trump on his sleeve it's affected
a lot of his coverage regularly he just
misses the point entirely
of new stories akbar god is great
sometimes i said under the most
beautiful of circumstances and and too
often we hear of it being said at
moments like this that's the story right
Jake the story is an Allah ho Akbar the
chant of jihad is when they are about to
blow things up that that's all sometimes
it's said in beautiful circumstances
that's the story of course not it's
posturing and it's preening and on other
times though he'll just outright lie
it's not normal to for a president to
make fun of disabled people right that's
not normal Yeah right correct when did
he make fun of disabled people when did
he make fun of somebody's disability it
didn't happen this was a regular attack
from the left during the 2016 primary
debates because there was some reporter
who was saying mean things about Trump
and he pretended to be [ __ ] when he
was impersonating him but Donald Trump
did precisely the same impersonation
when he was making fun of a general when
he was making fun of Ted Cruz when he
was making fun of himself actually he
was making fun of something that he
himself had done in the past he said oh
yeah I don't I don't know I you know I
wasn't being coherent or making sense
this was a total lie Jake Tapper
honestly peddled and how about some more
I want to ask you in Quebec City last
week a white right-wing terrorist opened
fire on a mosque a mosque filled with
innocent men women and children six
people were killed President Trump has
not said or tweeted one public word
about this you want to talk about
ignoring terrorism why hasn't the
president offered his sympathy to our
neighbors in the north gee Jake do you
still beat your wife
that is a fairer question than what you
just brought up to Kelly and Conway not
only is it a ridiculous in the position
and the defense that have puts the
interviewee in but it's just not
grounded in any reality we are know that
President Trump had already called the
the leaders of Canada and offered his
support and offered his condolences on
the phone so it isn't read did very he
publicly offered his support to the
neighbors to the north but that didn't
go with the narrative so in a Jake
Tapper he had to just he had to reinvent
history and reinvent the presidency
which he keeps trying to do he tried to
reinvent it with Stephen Miller Miller
wouldn't play along so we kicked him off
of this show now so he used to be a
journalist in the Obama days it's really
gone downhill yeah during the campaign
certainly during the administration he's
even admitted his naked partisan
advocacy on television on elective
action election that hates that we
really need that Hillary Clinton really
needs to maintain let's just put this on
the board we need to make Hilary Clinton
needs to keep a pencil we need it we
knew did you catch that did you catch
what he said he didn't say the Clinton
campaign he said well we really need a
homina homina homina I mean the Clinton
campaign and so the only way that we
will ever get into the oval Omaha oh
yeah is that hot in here is it hot new
CNN studios give me a break but he said
it himself he said we are upping the
team we are working for Hillary Clinton
which was no surprise to anyone who's
ever watched CNN but it was a little bit
sad for people who used to like Jake
Tapper because he used to be a
journalist that the language has
continued since he's been since
President Trump was inaugurated and
people accused President Trump accusing
reckless rhetoric extremist rhetoric how
about the extremist rhetoric from Jake
Tapper where President Trump's tweets
are windows into his soul unfiltered and
often seemingly unmoored unmoored and by
the way this is the perennial attack
against Republicans particularly against
Republican presidents and presidential
candidates they have to be crazy they're
all out of their minds they're all
mentally unfit to be President we're
seeing this now this is coming back up
against President Trump we'll talk about
it a little more later some of its
history with Ronald Reagan and Barry
Goldwater and even Dan Quayle even
George W Bush but he doesn't just stop
there he doesn't just question
president's mental capacities he also
questions his loyalties even the darkest
days of the Obama White House's war
against FoxNews the Obama White House
never banned Fox from attending any sort
of press gang goal or briefing this
White House does not seem to respect the
idea of accountability this White House
does not seem to value an independent
press there is a word for that line of
thinking the word is unamerican that
isn't true by the way Barack Obama did
try to disinvite Fox News from a press
gaggle I think in 2009 and it was only
because the rest of the press wouldn't
show up they were so offended by it that
they had to continue to invite them but
Obama actually did try to do that
nothing unprecedented at all how about
the final hit Jake if you are a soldier
in harm's way right now if you are a
hungry child in Appalachia or the
inner-city
if you were an unemployed worker in a
hollow shell of a steel town that's not
a president who seemed rather focused on
your particular needs and wants
that's a president focused on his bad
press it was unhinged a lot of Americans
are gonna watch that press conference
and think that guy is not focused on me
I don't even know what he's focused on
just the fact CNN just the facts I'm
Jake Tapper I'm a real journalist look
it looks like he was giving a campaign
speech looks like he himself was running
for president what is it about
journalist who say you know listen I
don't know any of these people and I'm
certainly not in their shoes but if I
were one of these wonderful Americans I
would hate this president I would hate
president Trump and you should too
totally totally pathetic and you know he
once said - he said no one is called
people who don't want Isis to move to
their neighborhood Islamophobic that has
never happened in the history of the
world it's all of this hysterical
dishonest word choice that Jake Tapper
has been engaging and it's glib its
snarky it's that cattiness it reduced
him from a real journalist to a caddie
high school girl really pathetic and I
hope he turns it around some of us hope
for that but trump derangement syndrome
hits us all and seems to have it in him